in ghosts of Tsushima you'll strengthen
Djinn throughout your journey unlocking
more tools and skills to make tougher
fights easier to take on since you can
choose different skills that will affect
your playstyle as you level up I'll go
over a few basic and advanced tips that
everyone should use and list what skills
are needed if you like something in
particular that you see you can
prioritize learning that in your skill
tree during your playthrough if you're
not worried about your ego and the game
is giving you a hard time pairing and
dodging especially during mob fights it
may be best to track down the charm of
mutant okami located early in the game a
spring fall shrine this charm gives
bigger timing windows for all of your
parries and dodges sin sparing and
dodging is an essential part of the game
this charm is very valuable throughout
the whole game if you make you more
efficient in combat especially if you
need to Parry and dodge multiple attacks
in a row some techniques are really well
with each other
so we've listed a couple combinations
that you may want as you level up and
grow stronger hair smoke bombs with a
chain assassination technique as you can
get an instant multi kill against
enemies caught in the smoke blast you
can type in and kick immediately into a
sticky bomb then concentrate to get a
badass-looking combo combined way of the
flame with moon stances tornado for a
flaming hot spin attack remember that
way the flame makes your attacks
unblockable and your moon stances
tornado has super armor which means you
cannot be interrupted during this attack
arguably the most overpowered ability in
the game is wind stances typhoon kick
finisher this unlockable kick forces a
knockdown state giving the enemy no
chance to retaliate and offering you an
instant kill option on normal opponents
and critical strengths and leaders well
it can be dodged sometimes and it
doesn't work on brute units it's
consistent effectiveness on everything
else and high damage makes this
extremely powerful
the bow gives you a chance to use a
familiar ability called concentrate slow
down time to a crawl and take time with
your shot you can twist this ability to
your advantage to make precise Perry's
easier as well simply pull out the bow
and concentrate by holding l2 and
tapping or three you can now concentrate
on the timing to react to the enemy
attack release l2 and then l1
immediately to parry exactly when you
know that enemy attack will strike
there's no delay between putting a bow
away a parry
so you'll land easy perfect Perry's like
this since resolve can't be refilled by
any sort of consumable you'll have to
find creative ways to refill it killing
enemies and finishing off terrified
enemies is the standard way but
standoffs in particular are the best way
to replenish resolve you can also level
up your parry to a resolved parry will
down a squad of enemies to one man and
parry farm him over and over until your
resolve is refilled killing hostile
wildlife such as boars and bears also
refills result it's possible to do a
pretty neat trick with your horse since
enemies don't suspect horses on their
own you can use it as disguise a
standoff range dismount on the far side
and whistle behind your companion when
the group of enemies come you can take
advantage of the chain assassination
skill to wipe out a squad or at least
gain the advantage against larger groups
thanks to your trusty steed an important
good habit you should have as you get
stronger and acquire more stances is to
make switching stances against enemy
types second nature
getting into the natural flow of
changing stances quickly and smoothly
gives you a huge advantage on staggered
damage output and puts much more
pressure on the right opponents
especially during hectic mob fights
remember that wind goes against spearmen
moon goes against fruits water against
shield men and stone against regular
swordsmen this will give you a huge
advantage in your battles while dodging
and paring are two good defensive
options remember that jumping is also a
viable tactic in battle you can jump
over most attacks in the game and you'll
want to learn when and how to avoid
these attacks to turn them to your
advantage this is especially useful
against red unblockable attacks doing
jump attacks including jumping sword
slash or jump kick are also considered a
jump themselves so learn to use it
against the right attacks hopefully
you've learned a thing or two that you
can take on to your next fight team if
you have any questions or have a neat
trick of your own don't be afraid to
comment down below and thanks for
watching
[Music]
you